[Music]
where did Russia come from why is it so
big and what are the differences between
it and its neighbors the answers lie in
an epic story of seafaring warriors
nomadic invaders and the rise and fall
of a medieval state known as heavenly
force in the first millennium a large
group of tribes spread through the dense
woodlands of Eastern Europe because they
had no writing system
much of what we know about them comes
from three main sources
archaeological evidence accounts from
literate scholars of the Roman Empire
and the Middle East and lastly an epic
history called the primary chronicle
compiled in the 12th century by a monk
named Nestor
what they tell us is that these tribes
who shared a common Slavic language and
polytheistic religion had by the seventh
century
split into Western Southern and Eastern
branches the latter stretching from the
kneestr River to the Volga and the
Baltic Sea as Nestor's story goes after
years of subjugation by Vikings from the
north who by the way did not wear horned
helmets in battle the region's tribes
were vaulted and drove back the North
met
but left to their own devices they
turned on each other such chaos ensued
that ironically the tribes reached out
to the foreigners they have just
expelled inviting them to return and
establish border
the Vikings accepted sending a prince
named Aurora and his two brothers to
rule with Rorick son Oleg expanding his
realm into the south and moving the
capital to Kiev a former outpost of the
Khazar Empire the Kiev and Roose was
born Bruce most likely deriving from an
Old Norse word for the men who Rove the
new princedom had complex relations with
its neighbors alternating between
alliance and warfare with the Khazar and
Byzantine empires as well as neighboring
tribes religion played an important role
in politics and as the legend goes in
1987 the Roose Prince Vladimir the first
decided it was time to abandon Slavic
paganism and send emissaries to explore
neighboring faiths put off by Islam's
prohibition on alcohol and Judaism's
expulsion from its holy land the ruler
settled on Orthodox Christianity after
hearing odd accounts of its ceremonies
with Vladimir's conversion and marriage
to the Byzantine emperors sister as well
as continued trade along the Volga route
the relationship between the two
civilizations deepened Byzantine
missionaries created an alphabet for
Slavic languages based on a modified
Greek script while loose Viking warriors
served as the Byzantine emperors Elite
Guard for several generations the Kiev
engross flourished from its rich
resources and trade its noblemen and
noble women married prominent European
rulers while residents of some cities
enjoyed great culture literacy and even
democratic freedoms uncommon for the
time but nothing lasts forever
fratricidal disputes over succession
began to erode
the power as increasingly independent
cities ruled by rival Prince's vied for
control the Fourth Crusade and decline
of Constantinople devastated the trade
integral to roasts wealth and power
while Teutonic Crusaders threatened
northern territories the final blow
however would come from the east
consumed by their squabbles arose
princes paid little attention to the
rumors of a mysterious unstoppable horde
until 1237 when 35,000 mounted archers
led by Batu Khan swept through cities
sacking Kiev before continuing on to
Hungary and Poland the age of Kiev
engross had come to an end its people
now divided in the East which remained
under Mongol rule a remote trading post
known as Moscow would grow to challenge
the power of the cons conquering parts
of their fragmenting Empire and in many
ways succeeding it as it absorbed other
Eastern or gross territories it
reclaimed the old name in its Greek form
Rusia meanwhile the western regions
whose leaders had avoided destruction
through political maneuvering until the
Horde withdrew came under the influence
of Poland and Lithuania for the next few
centuries the former lands of Kiev and
ruse populated by Slavs ruled by Vikings
taught by creeks and split by Mongols
would develop differences in society
culture and language that remain to the
present day
[Music]